Transcriber: Beyzanur Ertaş
Gözden geçirme: Emel Çırakoğlu
Herkese iyi akşamlar.
Değerli vaktiniz için de
teşekkür ediyorum.
Ben de doğaçlama bir konuşma
yapacağım öncelikle.
Aslında en çok merak ettiğim şu
an oğlum burada beni izliyor.
O yüzden de çok heyecanlıyım yani merakımı
bu şekilde inanılmaz bir şekilde
heyecana çeviriyorum.
Az önce söylendiği gibi İstanbul İktisat
Fakültesi Ekonometri mezunuyum.
Yüksek lisansa da birinci
olarak girmiştim okulda.
″Ayağa kalk!″tan önce aslında bence
daha da farklı bir konsept olan
karar verme mekanizması çok önemli.
Hepsi birbirini çünkü takip ediyor.
Zincirleme.
Örneğin hepimizin hayatında verdiği
bazı kararlar olabiliyor.
Bazen yol ayrımına gelebiliyoruz.
Doğru ya da yanlış ama bir şekilde
bir karar vermemiz gerekiyor.
Cesur olmamız gerekiyor.
Örneğin, kendimden
bir şey anlatmam gerekirse,
ben gençlik çağlarında, üniversite
zamanında burada çok fazla da genç var.
O yüzden belki bir örnek teşkil
eder diye düşünüyorum.
Bir karar vermem gerekiyordu.
Aynı dönemde hem okula
gidiyordum İstanbul Üniversitesi’ne
hem de rahmetli babamın işi vardı.
Ticaretle uğraşıyordu.
Onun işiyle ilgileniyordum.
Hem de birinci ligde basketbol
oynuyordum aynı dönemde.
Bu arada da modelliğe heves sarmıştım.
Bir şey seçmemiz gerekiyor
hayatta bazen.
Her şeyi de
bir anda yapamıyoruz.
Çok doğru bir karar verdiğime inanıyorum.
Çünkü hayat bundan sonraki aşamalarında
sizi farklı yere getiriyor.
Başka bir verdiğim güzel karar,
eski eşimle tanışmam.
Dolayısıyla oğlumun şu anda olması ve
son olarak da verdiğim
önemli üçüncü karar olarak da bu.
Rüzgar doğduğu zaman, oğlum.
Bir tarla aldım Çanakkale'den.
Onun doğumuyla aynı yaşta aslında 3
yıl dedi hanımefendi ama 15 yıl oldu.
Oğlum 15 yaşında.
Ondan sonra bir anda toprağa
ilgim başladı.
Bu ″ayağa kalk! ″
daha sonraları oluştu.
Bunu nereden anlıyoruz?
Pandemide ya da bazı gerçekleri
gördüğümüz zaman.
İstanbul’un karmaşasından bazen sahte
insanlarla karşılaştığınızdan yahutta
kendinizi başarısız hissettiğiniz zaman
veya düştüğünüz zaman,
sizi kaldıran bir şeyin olması lazım.
O aslında kendiniz, ondan sonra da toprak.
Benim için bu böyle oldu.
Burada
her zaman söylüyorum toprak elimdekiler
böyle kir değil, toprak ve çamur.
Toprak sizi kirletmiyor, toprak
sizi temizliyor.
Öncelikle ruhunuzu temizliyor.
Bakış açılarınızı geliştiriyor.
Bir şeyle uğraşmak, kendinizi daha
değerli hissetmenize sebep oluyor.
Örnek vermek gerekirse, atıyorum
hepimizin başına gelebilir.
Yani benim de mesela çok başarılı
dizilerim oldu.
Daha sonra yurtdışında da kariyer yaptım.
Yunanistan ve İspanya’da oynayan
dizilerim var.
Hala oynuyor şu an.
Fakat gene de.
Kendimizi yenilemek, ayağa kalkmak,
tekrar düşünmek, hayatı biraz daha
kaliteli ve biraz daha yavaş yaşamak
bence çok değerli diye düşünüyorum.
Bunu da bize doğa çok güzel gösteriyor.
Sabahleyin uyandığınız zaman bir
kere doğal bir eğitimimiz var.
Kuşların sesiyle uyanıyorsunuz,
onlar da uyanıyor aynı saatte.
İhtiyaçlarımız insan olarak zaten belli.
Yani uyanmak, uyumak, yemek yemek
ve kendinizi önemli hissetmek.
Bu çok değerli.
Dolayısıyla boşta olduğumuz zaman,
iş yapmadığımız zaman
kendimizi daha değerli hissetmek için,
ben böyle bir yola başvurdum açıkçası.
Ondan sonra da bu dünyanın içinde farklı
gerçekleri hissetmeye, farklı gerçekleri
görmeye başladım.
Ufak bir alanda da olsa
toprakla uğraştığınız zaman size
bambaşka bir enerji veriyor.
Dünya için farklı görüşleriniz
ortaya çıkıyor.
Çok basit örnekler de verebilirim
tarımla alakalı.
İşte, karbon dediğimiz yani kahverengi dal
parçaları, kağıt organik metalleri alıp
onun üzerine ve nitrojen dediğimiz
yeşil şeyleri.
İşte ne olabilir? Çim.
Yediğimiz gıdalar onların hepsini
harmanlayıp karıştırıp şöyle bir öbek
olduğu zaman bir, bir buçuk metre kadar.
Bir gün sonra içinde bazı tepkimeler olur
ve bu yaklaşık size iki ay sonra tertemiz
toprak olarak geri dönüyor.
Bunlara kompozit deniyor.
Yani bu gözlemlemeniz,
doğadaki rekabeti gözlemlemeniz sizi
yaşadığımız hayatta farklı bir
bakış açısı sağlıyor.
O da nedir işte herkesin
birbiriyle rekabeti.
Otlar yani yabani ot dediğimiz otların
bile ne kadar değerli olduğu.
Bunu...
anlatma sebebim
biz İstanbul’da ya da bir büyük şehirde,
Çanakkale’de, orada burada yaşarken
bunları görme şansımız yok.
Bunları ancak onun içinde olduğumuz
zaman gözlemleyebiliyoruz.
Biraz da heyecanlıyım, kusura bakmayın.
Çok fazla ne diyeceğimi bilmiyorum ama bir
şey, bir uyanış, bir şey sağlıyor sizde.
Ve ruhunuzu her zaman
temiz tutuyorsunuz.
İşte atıyorum yanlış yollara sapıyor,
saklıyorsunuz.
Daha doğru ve doğal yaşadığımızı
hissediyorum.
Yani en azından ben öyle hissediyorum.
Onun dışında karar verme konusunda
da şunları söyleyebilirim.
Zamanı geri alma şansımız yok sonuçta.
Ama en azından daha önceki
konuşmacıların yaptığı,
konuşmalardaki söyledikleri gibi
değindikleri gibi çok güzel bir konu.
Gerçekten hayal ettiğimiz, ulaşmak
istediğimiz şeylerin peşine gitmeliyiz.
Kararlarımızı yanlış dahi olsa verip ondan
sonra tekrar doğruyu bulmalıyız.
Hiçbir şey için geç olduğunu düşünmüyorum.
Herkese çok teşekkür ediyorum.
Konuşmamı kısa tuttum, kusura bakmayın.
Heyecanımı da mazur görün.
Çok sağ olun. Teşekkür ederim.